à thala votre ami qu à votre à licencier
l'émission préférée des français
by a écrit koh lanta à gauche merci
alors attendez le gaucher alors amené
alors alors on est confiné mais
apparemment les du cerveau aussi avait
combiné annonce alors années 90 et qui
me disent les inconnus club dorothée a
gagné à nice lé grandir c s'incline dans
les années 80 les 30% et les démissions
s'étonnant parce que c'est canal+ c'est
quand même mais confidentielle ça a duré
que deux saisons c'était formidable mais
un anus ses formidables comme léon
jouhaux appel oui mais c'est plus ça n'a
duré que ça dépend ça dépend comment est
fait le sondage si c'est un sondage d'y
assister ou spontanées c'était il ya
deux manières de poser la question à
vous et des émissions qui vont marquer
ses trente dernières années vous allez
répondre quoi alors moi années 90 je
vous le dis je réalisais pas ce que
c'était une révolution dans le domaine
du jeu mais les autres après les autres
moi j'aurais mis les nuls aussi sérieux
coup c'est long dans les années 2000
je pensais retrouver mon émission mari
qui va lier pas ben non précédent
quand c'est possible que mon émission
d'une jambe à pékin pas du tout ah oui
non mais écoutez l'émission n'était pas
pu poser ou tout simplement par des oui
ces années 2010 mais c'est logique ça
leur recherche appartement vous trouvez
ça normal que ça fonctionne très bien
dans l'esprit des gens s'ils pensent
tout de suite à ça parce que c'est quand
même fréquence est tout frais et si des
missions que les marchandises pour moi
c'est pas un bleu un peu alors c'est une
révolution
comme sion et comme n'oubliez pas les
paroles oui il avait raison on y parle
comme je vais enquêter avoir commencé
son visage quelques émissions et
quelques émissions que je vois là voilà
comment ça m'agace